aleve tinner voyage léger elle s'apprête
à aller chercher sa mère de l'autre côté
de l'atlantique
ukrainienne installé à montréal depuis
plus de dix ans sa vie et celle de son
conjoint ayoub ont été complètement
chamboulée par la guerre voir ça comme
ça pour des gens qui n'ont rien fait
pour heure
pour mériter ce sort la ccc c'est dur à
digérer c'est vraiment dur à digérer
c'est pas comme ça le crâne que j'ai
connu et à peine que le comment
ça va
le couple est allé rendre visite aux
parents d'aller petit n'at il y a à
peine six mois au delà et guennadi
habite kryviy rih une ville industrielle
du centre du pays lieu de naissance du
président zelensky menacé par les
troupes russes donc c'est beaucoup de
stress et en plus ma mère était
diagnostiquée avec un cancer de
l'intestin au mois de janvier c'était
une jour avant ça fait des 53 ans olena
a commencé ses traitements de
chimiothérapie au jour 4 de la guerre
ils ont été interrompus par des sirènes
comme celle ci qui l'ont forcé à se
réfugier au sous-sol de l'hôpital les
médecins lui ont dit de ne pas revenir
trop dangereux et les médicaments
commencent à manquer donc ces questions
de vie ou de mort on peut pas faire les
traitements puis il faut qu'elle soit
traitée ci est prête à se battre c'est
ma mère donc je ne peux pas la laisser
tomber
direction l'aéroport allez petit navarre
a mené sa mère aujourd'hui réfugié en
pologne
il aura fallu près de 48 heures après un
aller retour montréal varsovie ayoub est
là pour leur souhaiter la bienvenue il
est accompagné de la fille d'à les
petits nains que sa grand-mère ne
pensait plus revoir
elle a réussi elle a ramené olena qui
refusaient obstinément de quitter sa
maison
elle a dû laisser derrière elle son mari
qui est chirurgien orthopédiste il
soigne les soldats dit elle mais ils
manquent de tout
les sirènes résonnent toutes les nuits
explique-t-elle il faut dormir dans les
corridors et prier pour que les bombes
nous et par nous at il volé la pleurer
parce qu'il me dit et j'espère qu'ici
peut me traiter parce que sinon si je
dois retourner l'ukraine est la même pas
d'aéroport elle a pu entrer au pays
grâce à un visa de touriste encore
valide mais le plus dur reste à faire
cent des visiteurs a été transformée
dans le viseur spécial canada ukraine et
pour les personnes qui bénéficient de
fait ce visa leur en arrivant au canada
ils peuvent obtenir un permis de travail
ouvert ce permis de travail
explique-t-elle donne accès aux soins de
santé c'est également ce qu'indique le
ministre fédéral de l'immigration à date
dans
la seule question qui va être sait quels
documents ils vont pouvoir présenter aux
médecins
olena dort mieux maintenant mais elle
est déchirée
son corps est ici alors que sa tête et
en ukraine
elle se sent coupable d'être en sécurité
alors que son mari est là bas mais là
bas elle était condamnée à mort moi je
lui ai dit écoute maman on va pas te
laisser tomber on va trouver les
solutions mais je ne suis pas capable ap
pour côté je peux pas laisser ma mère
décédée le québec a aussi promis que les
ukrainiens auraient accès à des soins
mais on leur a remis aucun document et
elles ne savent pas quand elles pourront
aller à l'hôpital je le dis pas ça mais
je sens une pression énorme parce que
je suis accro au
jeu comme déjà pas de pays si j'avais
pas voir
elle compte bien faire de l'ena une
double survivante
quoi tu te sa part français qiao
craignent qu
est-ce qu il et j'ai réveillé fait
savoir que la guerre était ici sébastien
et desrosiers radio canada mon frère